family here we go hello for Amy okay so
so I just got back I just got back from
the Book of Henry so this movie was it
was bad it was bad it was
no it wasn't okay it was oh I don't I
don't know where to start I don't I do
not know where to start with this one
because it was just it was it it so the
first half of the movie is just like
insufferably twe while the second half
is is mind-blowing in in just how like
just just how how absurd it is and just
just it's it's it's flabbergasting when
you start watching the character to go
through these actions that there is is
no like sensible grounding element for
and this so it in in a weird way this
movie almost almost plays like a PG what
was this rated pg-13 okay
pg-13 so this almost plays like a pg-13
version of Burn After Reading in the -
to a degree to a degree this is this is
about stupid people making insane
decisions for ludicrous reasons and and
you you kind of want it to just be like
a dark comedy but it's it's played just
absolute
we straight just like just super serious
like the whole time and so so the first
half of the movie is is unbearably twee
so it's about it's about this kit named
Henry and now Henry is naturally just a
like a mega super genius like not just
good at something like good at
everything so the the opening scene of
the movie after the credits is like kids
doing doing like you know just just a
front of class essay presentation where
they've got to they have to talk about
my legacy and so the first kid is
talking about how he wants to be an
Olympic dodgeball champion and now these
kids are all like 11 so it's like that's
actually really hard to read at start
like I thought they were a little bit
younger because it starts off with this
kid you know talking about being an
Olympic dodgeball champion and the
lesson is like maybe a little for that
but it's still it's not really out of
the realm of the realm of reality like
kids kids want you know I don't know how
the world works whatever so next up next
up is Henry and Henry gets up and is
basically like French philosopher he's
like bullet or a arse
he just kept Travis the knife is
meaningless we are all but the dust no
more or less like he stands up and and
talks about how like life is fleeting
and we don't know we don't know what's
coming and like really the the like true
meaning of life is to leave a legacy of
kindness and goodness behind us and but
it's the whole thing is presented in a
really like cynical tone of voice and he
explicitly calls out the first kid about
how like yeah man like you don't need
like look at you you don't even know
that that dodgeball is into an Olympic
sport so he basically says it's like
yeah you know like the whole thing is
really like I'm so much smarter than
everyone else
the class because I'm so much more grown
up and mature than all of you who want
who want dumb things like to be Olympic
dodgeball champions come on Amy are our
hey hey no biting no biting no biting
okay and you might know to my notes I
mean the tweets that I wrote while I was
in the movie because there was like four
other people so that's the note that the
movie begins on is this this like class
presentation where Henry just like
schools the rest of the kids about how
like dumb their dreams are but then on
the way it looks like of course like
bell rings and everybody's going
everybody's filtering out and the
teacher pulls Henry aside and it's like
remind me again why we can't put you in
an advanced school and he spouts off
just like the most pre-canned you know
intellectual response about how about
how he socializing with an equivalent
pure group is good for my my moral and
social development and like so on and so
forth and so one of the things is like
technically true maybe I guess sort of
but like he clearly doesn't believe it
so and and everything that comes after
like this kid has so much control over
every aspect of his life because the
next 20 minutes after this are
essentially setting up the like he runs
the house you know it's like mom mom is
basically a functioning alcoholic and
she's really like not clued into the the
world that she lives in and Henry
handles all the finances and Henry
handles all of the like household needs
and Henry handles like everything while
she works her waitress job that Henry
keeps telling her like they keep
dropping through this through the like
first half of the movie like you don't
need to go to work anymore mom I told
you like you can take some time off you
don't need to work anymore mom because
she works his waitress job and just like
a tiny little diner
and right so she gets drunk with her
co-worker she plays video games
Henry's always like we need to do I need
to show you the fine
and she's like whatever you know haha
computers there's a bunch of gags about
how she doesn't know how to use a
computer and then it then to two threads
start being introduced alongside each
other the first is that Henry has
headaches and the second is the rear
window style he sees his neighbor what
he says he suspect he starts to suspect
the neighbor is the neighbor dude is
abusing his daughter is like his
sexually abusing his daughter his
stepdaughter so daughter is Henry's age
and yeah he sees suspicious activity and
then then then it just kind of like
accelerates super rapidly to the point
that like you know he sees her on the
bus and they don't they say she has
bruises but I didn't you don't see any
bruises like so she's just got her hair
like you know kind of covering one side
of her face which you know I mean fair
enough but they they don't like there's
no moment where she like brushes it
aside and you kind to get a glimpse like
oh she's got a black eye like all stuffs
going down so Henry just like sits there
in class like getting angrier and
angrier and then he gets up in the
middle of class barges into the
principal's office and starts yelling at
her about how he's filed so many reports
about this and they're not doing
anything and why isn't anyone taking him
seriously and it happened so fast and
it's it's like wait this is this is
there are predicate conversations here
you've already brought this up like what
this is it's a lot of information that
kind of comes out of nowhere so it's
apparently this thing that Henry's been
like thing
think about for a while and he tried
calling a Child Protective Services but
it turns out that that stepdads
brother is like the head of CPS and so
immediately
Henry starts scribbling all of these
notes in this red notebook and he starts
like going around town and I there's
this one moment where he's like on a
bridge he's on this like big causeway
bridge and he like looks up one side and
it goes looks out the other and takes
out his tape recorder is like you know
four hundred foot drop on on the south
side very deep water on the North puts
it away
I'm like this is kid planning planning
to hide a body what's what's going on
here and then he goes into a gun store
and like hides behind a gun rack as he
listens to it and makes notes as he
listens to it dude try to buy a gun
without registration and here's the guy
say so what if what if dominique sent me
and yeah okay so he takes all of these
notes and whatever then his headaches
get get worse and he dies about halfway
through the movie so the first half of
the movie is is basically a whole bunch
of twee crap at home that builds up to
nothing henry like making all of these
weird notes and then he gets sick and
dies and it's so predictable like the
way that the character is written is so
predictable that he got into the
hospital so he goes to the hospital and
he wakes up after surgery and i'm like
i'm amazed that they haven't
had a scene where Henry explains his own
illness to a doctor and as I as I am
composing a tweet making that joke Henry
starts explaining his own disease to a
doctor and to to the surgeon and now
surgeon Makati doctor doctor McCotter
s'en is kind of important
okay so Henry's in the hospital for a
bit and there's more scenes where Henry
like tells mom like no you got to you
got to pay attention to the finances
like this is really important and he's
like trying to tell her about like
stocks and like which stocks she needs
to watch and like the textiles you got
to pay closer attention to the textile
the energy stocks are largely tied up in
like subsidiary bonds and so and she's
got another because of kids dying and
then Henry dies and and he just kind of
vanishes like there's no there's no
funeral there's no funeral soon Henry
just dies
I mentioned there's no funeral scene
because it's it's going to be important
later but so Henry dies and the second
half of the movie just goes so far off
the rails as Henry's younger brother
Peter sees the red notebook and now
Henry had told Peter you got to make
sure mom reads the notebook but only mom
not you so Peter takes the notebook and
it's like mom you've got to read this
you got to read the teeth flips through
it a little bit and I guess kind of gets
the guess the edge and it's like
step-by-step instructions on murdering
Glenn the the neighbor like and and
there's a whole scene where they have an
entire back-and-forth conversation like
so mom
Peter end of the book have an entire
back-and-forth conversation where like
you know mom will raise an objection and
then they'll flip to a section in the
it's like you know it's like there has
to be something else that we can do flip
open the book why there's nothing else
you can do and it goes on like that and
then the movie stays in that mode for
like most of the rest of it well pretty
much like the rest of the other runtime
stays in that mode where mom like gets
convinced that she needs to do this
thing she needs to follow Henry's
instructions and murder
Glenn so you leave this cache of like
cassette tapes and that she's gotten a
Walkman so she's walking around with a
Walkman and earbuds in having these
conversations with the tape like it's
it's that that gag where a character is
listening to something that's
pre-recorded they already did this with
the book you may notice but so someone's
listening to something pre-recorded and
they keep you it's like this is insane I
don't know you think that's insane you
know that they they ask hypothetical
they ask questions out loud or express
distrust or just do things and the tape
recorder like syncs up with it perfectly
and it's like they don't just do that so
they already did it with the book then
they do it again with the tape recorder
over and over and over and over again
for like a solid half-hour and it's down
to things like Henery via tape recorder
walks mom through buying a sniper rifle
with a suppressor and a night-vision
scope and oh dang it what kind of like
soft head ammunition that's going to
like explode like shatter once it once
it it hits a target so it's going to be
like almost impossible to trypsin and
she does it she does these things like
the tape recorder tells her what to say
including name-dropping Dominique in
order to like buy this gun
off-the-book oh by the way she also
discovers that she had like six hundred
thousand dollars in cash in a checking
account and untold amounts worth of
investments because because Henry is is
perfect and amazing and has made them
quite wealthy
you know like actually before she buys
with a gun like Henry the the capes walk
her through like all right you got a
good it's like okay go up to the ATM and
withdraw $500 and then if you get to
another ETM within 20 minutes you can
withdraw more money like basically if
you can hit three ATMs within 20 minutes
then you won't hit the daily withdrawal
limit okay well this is she's she's rich
like she has six hundred thousand
dollars in a checking account she can
just go into a bank and take out five
grand and the teller like that's not
suspicious behavior if you have six
hundred thousand dollars in cash
withdrawing a like big chunk of like
that's not suspicious it's not
suspicious when you're rich anyway
anyway so she buys a gun
she buys respectful and goes out and
starts practicing with it guided of
course by the tapes every step of the
way and Henry has already like bought
her a new car that he has stashed in a
parking lot unlike the other side of
town so that she just needs to go pick
it up and it's going to make a better
getaway vehicle because no one in the
neighborhood will recognize it because
it's not her it's not the car that she
normally drives and and oh my god so
there's a scene where she goes to
confront Glenn so this is after Henry's
death this is this is right around the
time that she's really like convinced
herself that she's going to go through
with it and so
she goes she goes to Glenn house Glenn's
house and the the the girl is on the
stairs she she asks the girl I don't
remember her name she's not she's not a
character she's barely a plot device
she's she's barely present in the movie
so like whatever but uh she's having
this non conversation he's like oh how
are things going okay and and longs like
it'll get easier
soon wink like she doesn't actually wink
but it's like it's so like oh the line
delivery is so loaded it'll get easier
soon oh oh I need to talk timeline okay
so one of the things is established
early in the movie is that the there is
a talent show next week when mom has
this conversation it's the day before
the talent show so all of this from so
Henry has gotten sick died and mom has
become a hardened killer who is
comfortable with a sniper rifle in the
span of a week or less van because this
is now the night before like Souter
pretense for going over is like I need
you to sign some papers but she's using
the papers so it's just say like you
know parental release for him like hey
I'm taking because she's gonna bring
daughter over to she's gonna bring her
to the talent show because Glenn's gonna
stay home because he's not big on going
to that kind of stuff like whatever and
but she then uses the signature to like
forge custody papers giving her custody
of the girl in the events of but like
and she's of course got to tape recorder
playing and Henry's walking her through
it and is like I back dated the
a year using a signature lifted from
this other neighbor who died like six
months ago and it's like okay so talent
show comes up and mom is like a
chaperone they're like standing by the
door you know so that you've got an
alibi
and then it's like once everything
starts she like puts in the tape
recorder and it's like Henry is like all
right online on my three one two three
hits the watch 45 minutes gotta go jump
to the car starts driving and it's like
intercutting mom going and getting her
like death trap set up uh with with the
talent show and I was going right at the
moment that I was going to make a gag
about the about a like really bad
reference to the baptism scene in
Godfather where it's cutting between
Michael son being baptized and Michael's
goons uh assassinating assassinating
some of the other the other crime
families in the in the city right at the
time that are going to make that
comparison mom's like getting the gun
set up and like adjusting the scope and
and back at the talent show a girl
starts singing Amazing Grace
so it's intercutting you know rich
tonight okay so she learns bled out into
the woods it advised mechanisms that
make no sense whatsoever
she looks Glenn out into the woods and
is like lining up this the shot and
she's got through the headphones on and
there's this big Rube Goldberg
contraption oh that's another thing is
that enry
also abilities with Goldberg machine and
it's it starts like she accidentally
bumps it and it's set up as a joke
because it's like oh you you know ie
eliminate all distractions and right
then she like slips and hits it and
starts going and of course it's making
all this noise she's like lining up the
shot and then it ends and like this
thing slips down is all these Polaroids
of like her kids and then she has this
moment like she's ready to shoot this
guy in the head oh there was a line
right when she's practicing the scene
when it goes into the scene where she's
practicing with the gun there's the line
alright mom
so plywood is only slightly thicker than
the human skull and but so anyway so she
looks at all these pictures of her kids
and then she has a smooth fertilization
that she listened to a tape recorder of
her dead son ever dead eleven-year-old
son like telling her how to murder this
guy she's like you're just a kid and so
she like walks out of the kids little
Clubhouse and Glen has like come up it
was like what the hell's going on and
she could she stand there with this
giant gun you know and she just puts it
down it's like I know what you did I
know what you're doing I'm gonna ruin
you I'm gonna you know they have this
confrontation and he calls he calls the
cops on he's like actually the police
commissioner so he calls like the
sheriff on her and goes goes back home
and she jumps in the car and like to get
back to the school on time to cover her
alibi and Oh backing up a little bit
when they get to the talent show
doctor Makati shows up because Peter
invited him
he shows up because the younger brother
of his dead patient invited him yeah
okay
so she she gets back and that's
intercutting with Glenn back at home as
Glenn kind of realizes it is like little
house of cards is like crumbling around
him and the police all show up like this
the framing of it is really weird
because like he called his own people to
come get her so they come up to his
house but it's framed as though they're
coming to get him which is sort of the
intentional implications that he feels
like you know this is all collapsing
because he gets a phone call from his
brother who's like we're going to have
to open an investigation and then he
shoots himself and yeah so back at the
talent show she gets there kind of just
in time as as Peter is doing his act is
doing is doing his talent act and his
talent Act is he's got a chest it's like
I'm going to make my brother reappear
and when I'm done he will be in the
midst of all of us and then he does a
thing opens the chest
nothing happens Henry where are you
Henry where are you
kicks it and it starts spewing out
snowflakes like fake snow fake snow that
it sprays all over the auditorium and
starts raining down wafting down covers
covers everyone these snowflakes and the
audience stands up and and just like
standing ovations applause I like it is
okay
the visual implication is the he is
scattered
Henry's ashes over the crowd
so immediately after it means easily
after the talent show like they step
outside and the police are there and
they're like oh step Deadshot Glenn shot
himself so like you know Child
Protective Services wants to talk to her
now and it just kind of like quickly
montages through like the outside the
courthouses you hear voiceover real life
we award custody to to you know soldiers
and it's like instant like just just so
she she just gets folded right into the
family taking Henry's place and the
final emotional beat the I don't even
know I had okay okay I honestly don't
know if I want to spoil this for people
because if you're going to see this the
the final emotional beat of this movie
is so amazing as a cherry on top of just
a awful movie that I don't last was so
if you if if you intend on seeing this
like I've spoiled 90% of the movie and
I've missed a lot of the good stuff in I
have missed a lot of the like just oh
man moments but this last one I'm going
to leap for you so so skip ahead if if
you don't if if you do plan on seeing it
like that that is one thing that I want
I want you to I want you to know that
something is coming but I don't want you
to know what it is
so skip ahead if you're in that camp
otherwise okay so there's there's this
leitmotif throughout the movie where so
Peter and Henry sleep in the same room
you know they've got they've got beds in
the same room
every time it's time for bed mom like
stands at the door and there's like this
little dinosaur nightlight she's like on
or off and it's always like Peter says
on Henry says off and then - the door
open or closed Peter says open Henry
says closed and if like that every time
but then she like alternates so like the
first time she turns on the dinosaur but
closes the door and then the next time
she leaves the dinosaur off but leaves
the door open and then the final moment
so there's this whole scene where oh
it's even more perfect alright there's
also an earlier scene where mom calls
Henry on shilada number one as she tucks
him in and calls Peter on shilada number
two at when she tucks him in and then
there's a conversation between them
where Peter's like why why is he on
chalan number one and she's like well
because he's older he he got here first
and say whatever but so there's this
whole conversation as you know so the
girl so Peter is now sleeping in Henry's
bed and the girl is sleeping in Peters
old bed and she tucks them in and calls
Peter on shilada number one and the girl
butterfly number one and goes over to
the door and holds up the dinosaur and
it's like on or off and they both say on
open or closed and they both say closed
and then the door closes and the credits
roll
the final emotional beat of this movie
is is that she has just like slotted
perfectly into this family because
because Henry's spirit or legacy or
essence like has has infected them or
has like just just like it's all about
it's it's it's trying to be about like
okay the impact of people in other
people's lives but it it makes Henrico
to be like a poltergeist a like haunting
spirit who's like it possesses people
and overrides their free will and theirs
and by calling her a butterfly there's
there's this implication that like in
her Henry has been reborn so so go see
this movie so go see it you you owe it
you owe it to yourself to bear witness
it's
it's been a while since I've seen
anything remotely like it and so I won't
I am NOT I am NOT going to be surprised
at all if like Kennedy is having some
some very serious discussions about the
future of Star Wars after this weekend
because Colin Trevorrow is currently
slated to direct Episode nine and I get
the feeling that that might change after
this this is bad like okay so Colin
trevorrose is his first movie to get any
real any real notice was safety not
guaranteed which I thought was okay it
wasn't it it wasn't really that special
like so it came out in you know kind of
the the new indie wave the the indie
rock wave in in the late middle a dot
and you know it it was not as good as I
Heart Huckabees
or Juno but it was okay and Jurassic
world was just a mess and now this this
is this is astonishing in just how like
the the failure to balance tone or even
just like step back and ask like is this
a good decision [ __ ] is this what we
want to do is this what we're doing
right now it's it's amazing also the
movie feels the movie feels really dated
in a lot of ways like it very much feels
like it it belongs in the stable of Wes
Anderson imitators but it's not good
like it's not a good Wes Anderson
imitation and it's not an actual Wes
Anderson imitation it just kind of it
has that same kind of sense and
sensibility like it has that very Manic
Pixie dream girl sort of twee you know
saccharine a cute tone about it so like
you know it's like oh mom plays video
games and she she gets drunk with her
friend but it's just kind of wacky
and but it's bad but it's wacky but it's
bad but it's wacky and she plays ukulele
with the kids and she's really like
she's not really mom she's like the kids
best friend but the movie can't go I
decide if that's the badge it's like if
she's a bad mom or if she's a good mom
like if she's actually like if she's
actually negligent which she kind of is
or if she's like I don't know like
you're a great mom you've been in
there's there's an entire conversation
when when Henry's dying where she's like
I never learned how to be a mother and
Henry tells her I never taught you how
to do that okay so so yeah it's it's a
mash-up of every precocious every
precocious kid movie from like the late
80s through the mid auth smashed
together you know there's a what do we
got where is my list little man Tate I
know was one of the Radio Flyer like I
mean because like yeah so Radio Flyer
definitely little man Tate where's my
list where's my list pay it forward
meets rear window meets just the kid
from Jerry Maguire go there's another
scene another thing is that so like
Henry is this total I don't get why
anybody likes him so he's he's not only
like smarter than the rest of his peers
by you know
a mile he's he's really self-righteous
about it like he's super smug about it
and the movie opens with him being like
an obnoxious dick right in front of the
class but we're told repeatedly that
like everyone loved Henry and everyone
wants to be his friend despite the fact
that he's like an antisocial prick you
know everything that we've seen is that
this kid is a buzzkill he like hates
everything he's exactly the kind of kid
who you just know that if you didn't get
brain cancer and die that he's the kid
he's gonna like spent his teenage years
being like Oh pop music is like the
worst I listened to the Zeppelin um you
know you just know
that's who he's gonna be like he is
exactly that [ __ ] and but everyone
apparently likes him like he doesn't he
doesn't get the crap beaten out of her
every day for being you know smug and
but even then like when we're told
everybody likes it we're just kind of
told that everybody likes him because we
don't really meet any other characters
okay there's one other kid in his class
that you kind of meet aside so there's
girl and then dumb kid and so there's
dumb kid from the beginning and then you
learn like no one else they don't even
have any other kids in the class like
have a one off line about like is Henry
gonna be okay
like there's dumb kid has speaking parts
no one else has speaking parts the
moment Henry dies Peter immediately like
is possessed by his spirit and is
suddenly like pep-talking mom and like
teaching her how to be a real mom and it
becomes a mechanical genius overnight
this we will we will be hearing we will
be hearing from this again absolutely go
go experience this don't worry about
giving your money to an awful film
it won't make a difference this is going
to bomb no one is going to go see this
this is it just yeah so enjoy sitting in
an empty theater and watching a
incomprehensibly poorly considered movie
and and just it's it's Winter's Tale
cubed like yeah yeah